♪ ♪
>> Greg: IT IS FUN WATCHING
TRUMP HATERS DO HIS WORK FOR
HIM.
CHUCK SCHUMER SUDDENLY.
THE PRESIDENT'S MOUTHPIECE.
OR SUPREME COURT JUSTICE
JOHN ROBERTS REBUKED TRUMP FIRST
THING THAT THEY WERE OBAMA
JUDGES.
TRUMP FIRED BACK AND SAID COME
ON, EVERYONE KNOWS WE HAVE
JUDGES WITH POLITICAL LEANINGS.
THE MEDIA DROOLED OVER ROBERTS
AND CHUCK ANGLED FOR SPOTLIGHT.
"I DON'T AGREE VERY OFTEN WITH
CHIEF JUSTICE ROBERTS ESPECIALLY
HIS PARTISAN DECISION BUT I AM
THANKFUL TODAY THAT HE ALMOST
ALONE AMONG REPUBLICANS STOOD UP
TO PRESIDENT TRUMP AND FOR AN
INDEPENDENT JUDICIARY."
IN ONE BREATH, CHUCK MADE
TRUMP'S POINT PERFECTLY.
A CHIEF JUSTICE MAKES PARTISAN
DECISIONS.
THEN HE NOTES ROBERTS POLITICAL
PARTY, REVEALING CHUCKIE LABELS
JUDGES TOO.
IT USED TO TAKE DAYS BETWEEN
PEOPLE MOCKING TRUMP OVER WHAT
HE SAYS AND THEN ADMITTING HE
WAS RIGHT.
NOW IT HAS COLLAPSED INTO
SECONDS.
OR AS CHUCK SAYS, TRUMP IS WRONG
AND HERE'S WHY I AGREE WITH HIM.
IT REVEALED THAT IT'S NOT THAT
TRUMP'S CRITICS HAVE A PROBLEM
WITH THE TRUTH.
THEY HAVE A PROBLEM WITH HIM
SAYING IT.
SCHUMER ACCIDENTALLY FOR ONCE
SPOKE IT TOO.
MAYBE HE DIDN'T MEAN TO BUT WHEN
THE ONLY THING LEFT TO SAY IS
WHAT TRUMP HAS BEEN SAYING, HE
HAD NO CHOICE.
WELL DONE, CHUCK.
IT'S LIKE YOU SAT IN TRUMP'S LAP
WHILE HE MOVED YOUR MOUTH.
I'VE A FEELING THIS MIGHT BE THE
TWEET OF THE YEAR.
>> Dana: US IN THE SPORTS
WORLD, WE WOULD CALL IT AN "OWN
GOAL."
I THINK PRESIDENT TRUMP WOULD BE
BETTER OFF IN THIS CASE, MANY
CASES, ARGUING ON THE MERITS.
INSTEAD OF SAYING IT'S BECAUSE
YOU'RE A DEMOCRAT THEY DON'T
AGREE.
NO, YOU'RE WRONG ON THE MERITS
AND WHAT WE TELL YOU WHY.
WE'RE GOING TO APPEAL THIS AND
TAKE IT TO THE SUPREME COURT AND
WE ARE WIN.
INSTEAD OF TALKING ABOUT SHOULD
HE WIN ON THE MERITS WHICH HE
MIGHT, THEN WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
THIS.
>> Greg: GERALDO, WHAT I FIND
INTERESTING, IT'S A NEW TREND
WHERE PEOPLE GET UPSET ABOUT
WHAT TRUMP SAID AND THEN FOUR
DAYS LATER THEY GO BUT HE HAS A
POINT.
THE WILDFIRES EVEN, HE HAD SAID
THERE WAS LOT OF MISMANAGEMENT,
FEDERAL AND STATE WIDE.
EVERYBODY GOT ON HIS CASE.
>> Geraldo: IT'S A GOOD
EXAMPLE.
>> Greg: AND THEN CALIFORNIA
EVEN ADMITTED IT.
>> Geraldo: WITH ALL DUE
RESPECT THE CHIEF JUSTICE, HE'S
WRONG.
WITH ALL DUE RESPECT TO THE
MINORITY LEADER IN THE SENATE,
HE IS DOPEY WRONG.
AS AN ATTORNEY, I CAN TELL YOU
LAWYERS -- YOU FIND THE
CONSERVATIVE JUDGE, LIBERAL
JUDGE.
ISSUES LIKE OBAMACARE,
GAY MARRIAGE, TRANSGENDER RIGHT.
THESE ARE FRAUGHT POLITICAL
ISSUES AND THAT'S WHY THE
PRESIDENT PUT SUCH STOCK IN
SELECTING JUDGES.
HE KNOWS THAT THEY WILL AFFECT
THE POLITICAL DESTINY OF THE
NATION.
TO PRETEND THAT THE JUDICIARY IS
APOLITICAL IS SOPHOMORIC AND
NAIVE AND INTENTIONALLY WRONG.
>> Greg: IT IS LIKE SCHUMER
FORGOT ALL ABOUT OBAMA STACKING
THE COURT.
>> Kennedy: THAT'S WHAT EVERY
PRESIDENT DOES.
THE EXECUTIVE AND LEGISLATIVE
BRANCHES IS USING THE JUDICIARY
TO GET THEIR WORK DONE.
I HAVE AN ISSUE WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP LAUNCHING
EXECUTIVE ORDERS, THE SAME WAY
WITH PRESIDENT OBAMA, THEY GET
UNDONE BY THE COURTS AND THEY
HAVE TO WORK THROUGH THE SYSTEM.
INSTEAD OF CRAFTING THEM THE WAY
THEY SHOULD COME I ALSO HAVE AN
ISSUE WITH SOME OF THE THINGS
DEMOCRATS HAVE SAID ABOUT THE
PRESIDENT IN REGARDS TO THIS
PARTISAN INFIGHTING.
IN TERMS OF IMMIGRATION.
BUT WERE GOING TO GET TO THAT
LITTLE WHILE.
OF COURSE THERE ARE DIFFERENT
WAYS OF INTERPRETING THE
CONSTITUTION THEN IT'S NOT
NECESSARILY LIBERAL AND IT'S NOT
NECESSARILY CONSERVATIVE.
BUT THERE'S A DIFFERENCE.
AN OBJECTIVE ORIGINALIST
INTERPRETATION OF THE
CONSTITUTION TENDS TO ALIGN MORE
WITH ROB LUKENS.
THOSE ARE JUSTICES LIKE
ANTONIN SCALIA AND THEN THERE
ARE PEOPLE WHO SEE THE
CONSTITUTION IS A LIVING
DOCUMENT.
>> Jesse: I WANT TO ADDRESS MY
MOTHER.
SHE SAID THAT I USED A RACIAL
SLUR BECAUSE I COULDN'T
PRONOUNCE SOME NAMES OF SOME
DEMOCRATIC CANDIDATES.
I WAS TALKING ABOUT SWALWELL AND
KINKENLUPER.
>> Dana: IT'S WHY WE WERE
DYING OVER HERE.
>> Geraldo: I LOVE YOUR
MOTHER.
I WOULD LOVE TO HEAR YOUR MOTHER
SPEAKING TO YOU.
>> Greg: I KNEW THAT YOU WERE
TALKING ABOUT ERIC SWALWELL.
>> Jesse: YOU DIDN'T JUST
ASSUME I WAS RACIST, LIKE MY
MOM.
I WANT TO SAY WE ARE STARTING
WITH THE ASSUMPTION THAT
POLITICIANS ARE SMART.
POLITICIANS AREN'T SMART.
THESE ARE NOT SMART PEOPLE,
SPECIAL PEOPLE.
SCHUMER, PEOPLE KISS HIS BUTT
BECAUSE HE'S POWERFUL AND HE
COULDN'T MAKE THEIR LIFE
MISERABLE.
THEY READ OFF NOTES.
THEY CAN'T MEMORIZE ANYTHING.
THEY DON'T EVEN KNOW WHAT'S IN
THE BILLS THEY PASS.
MOST OF THESE PEOPLE ARE FAILED
LAWYERS WHO COULDN'T HACK IT IN
THE REAL WORLD.
THINK ABOUT HOW LAZY, ON
INTELLECTUAL THEY ARE.
EVERYTHING GOES WRONG.
THE BORDERS ARE OPEN AND THEN
PEOPLE GET MAD AT POLITICIANS
AND THEY SAY NO, IT WAS YOU.
IT WAS YOU.
THE ONLY THING THEY ARE GOOD AT
IS THE REASONING PEOPLE'S MONEY
AND THEN SPENDING OTHER PEOPLE'S
MONEY.
IT'S AMAZING CHUCK SCHUMER STILL
HAS THIS JOB.
>> Kennedy: YOU HAVE JUST MADE
A VERY LIBERTARIAN ARGUMENT.
THANK YOU FOR THAT.
THE FAILURE OF GOVERNMENT.
>> Geraldo: THIS BY ALEXANDRIA
OCASIO-CORTEZ IS GOING TO TAKE
OVER THE HOUSE.
MY FAVORITE CONGRESSWOMAN ELECT.
SHE COMES FROM A DISTRICT, I
KNOW IT WELL.
SHE IS SO SMART.
SHE IS SO MOTIVATED.
SHE TAKES --
>> Greg: GERALDO IS TRYING TO
BAIT US.
>> Jesse: I LIKE HER.
SHE SHOULD RUN.